I'm joined Now by retired Air Vice
Marshall Sean Bell hello again to you
Sean this is something we've been
talking about
um this morning confirmation that they
are or they have plans to send how
significant is it
yeah it's worth remembering president
zlensky in Ukraine if they are to
Prevail in this war they need to get
onto the offense there's been much talk
about a spring offensive but if that is
to work they desperately need tanks now
they have a lot of Tanks um but they're
all former Soviet Union tanks which are
relatively vulnerable particularly if
they're going to go on the attack
against Russia so what they need is
modern tanks to be able to for this
spring offensive there's been lots of
speculation for days that the UK will
give up some Challenger two main battle
tanks that are shown here one of the
features of this tank has been around
since the mid 90s but it's got this chop
them armor on it which will take a
direct hit from a relatively modern t-72
Russian tank and that won't destroy it
the downside of this is that these tanks
there's not that many of them about the
only users of them the UK and Oman we've
only got I think 227 of them I
understand 143 are due to be upgraded to
Challenger 3 leaves only about 79 that
are available that might have been
disposed of so there is the potential
but when you have a tank available in
small numbers the spares are only
available in small numbers it's a
specific round that's fired from these
because it's got a rifle barrel so
they're not available in big numbers
either but
um you know it does appear that if that
the president our prime minister has a
confirmed today that in a conversation
with president zielinski that the UK is
going to provide we understand about 10
of these tanks to Ukraine woefully
shorter the numbers of tanks that they'd
actually which is probably well over a
hundred but of course there just aren't
the numbers of those to provide the key
reason for this though appears to be
unlocking European opportunities to
export The Leopard 2 tank which is much
more broadly used in uh is shown here it
there's over 2000 of these in service
with 13 different countries therefore
the Ukraine could benefit from a
significant number of these without
significantly denting
um that the stocks from Europe the
challenge is it's a German tank and the
German therefore holds the licensing for
this and they will only agree to people
exporting it so by the U UK taking
initiative it means Germany potentially
will follow suit we understand Poland's
looking to potentially go up up to 14 of
these tanks very smoothly the challenge
of course these are take a long time to
train people so if you're going to have
these tanks one thing putting the tanks
into into the Ukraine it's quite another
getting trained Crews ready and if they
want to mount a spring offensive they
need to get moving with these
deployments
okay um let's go back to solidar the
Salt mining town what do we know about
what's happening there who controls it
well the fighting's been very very
Fierce hasn't it and the question is has
it fallen or not and what does that
actually mean
um for some it means that there's no
longer any Ukrainian troops in there
just Russian troops from a military
perspective that this is more of a
judgment about who controls the town
rather than actually getting rid of
everybody there's no doubt there are
still Ukrainian soldiers in there
Russia's got to do some mopping up but
almost certainly the ukrainians have
suffered a defeat in solidar the big
issue though is that they've exacted a
huge toll on the Russian convicts uh the
the casualty rates are astronomic and
actually almost certainly the worry was
that Russia would then suddenly
capitalize and encircle Bahamut whereas
in fact it looks almost certain they're
going to have to catch their breath and
it will be a while before they're ready
to take that next step for me though the
really interesting part of this is that
the Wagner group who was the lead for
the battle here claimed Victory a few
days ago but both and Ukraine said
solidar hasn't fallen yet yesterday the
Kremlin said that it had fallen and even
though Ukraine you know doesn't agree
with that at the moment but it's all
about pragosian here that's that's the
real issue
um and uh it was only literally at the
end of the uh the battle
um President Putin acknowledged the
great support that the Russian army had
done the assault troops the armored
vehicles the artillery didn't even
mention the Wagner group and it was only
six hours later that he acknowledged
that they had actually been a part in
this okay Sean Bill thank you so much
we're going to leave it there thank you